reports of chaos at the Mississauga
Convention Center on Sunday an event
that was supposed to be for Children and
Families turned sour for some attendees
say they were met with long Waits and
for those who were able to get inside
the event they were left disappointed
Erica Vella has been following the story
and has more Erica well Alan the event
was called a dream is a Wish Your Heart
Makes and it advertised over 40 local
vendors face painting and 15 Disney
characters to meet and greet it was
supposed to be a fun day for families
with kids but we have spoken to many
people who say it was anything but
we love Disney and it just thought it
would be a fun afternoon and it turned
out to be a little bit of a traumatic
experience this mother says she was
faced with parking nightmares and long
lines people waiting to get inside the
Mississauga Convention Center to attend
a market that boasted Disney characters
and kid-friendly events she says she
waited an hour and a half with her
daughter to get into the market and when
she got inside it was pretty chaotic and
disorganized and a little bit scary and
claustrophobic it was almost like the
amount of boost that they had they
didn't have enough capacity in the room
for the amount of Booth let alone the
people that were walking through at one
point Mississauga Fire and peel police
were called no one is out here leading
anything this is a very poorly organized
event the event was organized by
elevated Society Market some attendees
told global news they had purchased
tickets to the event days before but
were unable to get in in an Instagram
post the organ said tickets were
non-refundable 30 days prior to the
event any unforeseen circumstances were
out of their control according to the
event page a portion of ticket proceeds
were to be donated to Make A Wish
Foundation but a spokesperson with
Make-a-Wish said they weren't aware of
the event until last week our people did
reach out or attempt to reach out when
we saw that media story last week but to
date we haven't been in contact with the
event organizers at all so we've had no
opportunity to figure out what their
thinking was behind us including us as
their beneficiary so far Make-a-Wish
Canada says no donation has been made
from the elevated Society Market or the
event but it just turned out to be a
disaster inside the market for only 10
minutes she's now reached out for a
refund just in the fact that I wanted my
daughter to have a fun day and I think
what was so disheartening for me was
that she was crying and it was a
complete opposite of what we expected
now the event organizers posted on their
social media saying the issues were with
the venue now we've reached out to the
Mississauga convention center but have
not yet heard back the organizers of the
event also said police and fire were
called because fire routes were
obstructed and the lines were long to
get inside the event because people were
there without tickets even though
tickets weren't available at the door
now as for the donations We are
continuing to follow up with Make-A-Wish
Foundation to see if donation is
eventually made they say they are hoping
to get in touch with the organizers
about this we've also reached out to the
organizers but not have have not yet
heard back Alan thank you Erica